am tiefsten punkt des marianengrabens
hat ein chinesisches forschungsteam
riesen viren gefunden die größer als
alle anderen bekannten virenarten sind
das ging gerade nach den letzten monaten
der pandemie etwas beunruhigend also was
hat es mit den wehren auf sich und kann
es für uns gefährlich werden und was
macht es seltsam es da unten am ende der
welt einmaliges mit anderen lebewesen
klicks umsatz im future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen und jetzt lasse ich
mal team vom kanal asto comics tvr an
der hat das thema nämlich recherchiert
und noch eine wichtige ankündigung
bleibt also unbedingt ran der
marianengraben ist vermutlich die
bekannteste tiefsee rinne unseres
planeten er liegt im westlichen
pazifischen ozean und es eingebettet
zwischen zwei kontinentalplatten und
zwar zwischen der philippinischen und
der pazifischen platte erstreckt sich
bis zu elf kilometer in die tiefe womit
die tiefen des marianengrabens noch zu
den unerforschten orten unserer erde
gehören unstreitig ist dass die tiefste
stelle der weltmeere im marianengraben
liegt aber es gibt so ein bisschen
streit darüber welche stelle das genau
ist es gibt nämlich mehrere anwärter und
die unterscheiden sich alle nur so ein
paar meter was die bestimmung eben sehr
schwierig macht die beiden favoriten für
die tiefste stelle sind das challenger
tief mit einer tiefe von 10
1994 metern und das wird ja steve 1 in
einer tiefe von 11.000 34 metern es gibt
aber eben bei beiden messung
ungenauigkeiten von so plus minus 40
metern deswegen kann man es nicht genau
festlegen der marianengraben ist
jedenfalls ein unfassbar spannender ort
vor allem in hinblick auf die flora und
die fauna denn auch in diesem
unvorstellbaren tiefen existiert noch
leben hier sind wir zum beispiel die
aufnahme eines tiefseeroboter des social
webs der university of aberdeen aus
einer tiefe von 8.000
145 meter und ist ein roboter hat da
unten tatsächlich noch fische gefunden
die dort gut gedeihen und nicht nur
fische sondern auch gigantische krebse
die viel größer sind als ihre verwandten
weiter oben in den ozean dieses phänomen
das tier in der tiefsee teilweise größer
zu werden scheinen als verwandte arten
weiter oben in den meeren bezeichnet man
als tiefsee gigantismus und das spielt
für die geschichte mit den viren eine
gigantische
nun hat man nämlich herausgefunden dass
nicht nur fische und krebse von diesem
tiefsee gigantismus betroffen sind
sondern auch viren das chinesische
forschungsschiff chan chan hat mit hilfe
eines tiefseeroboter sedimente aus knapp
elf kilometern tiefe im marianengraben
nach oben geholt ein chinesisches
forschungsteam hat sich natürlich sofort
an die untersuchung dieser tiefsee
sedimente gemacht das ergebnis im
marianengraben wimmelt ist vor so
genannten mini viren minimieren gibt es
auch auf der erdoberfläche und man hat
sie vor knapp 30 jahren entdeckt lange
zeit geht man allerdings davon aus dass
es sich hier gar nicht um viren handelt
da das mini wo es eine wirklich
erstaunliche größe erreicht erstmals hat
man in der stadt bedford entdeckt und
deswegen nannte man es anfangs bradford
cox und stufte es als bakterium ein als
man dann den fehler entdeckte taufte man
ist auf den namen mimi king weiteres
also zu deutsch ungefähr täuschen des
virus kurz mini virus mit ihren haarigen
fasern und körpern die bis zu 700
nanometer breit sein können sind sie so
riesig dass man sie mit einem ganz
normalen lichtmikroskop erkennen kann
das wäre bei fast allen anderen
virenarten völlig unmöglich das ist
allerdings nicht die einzige
besonderheit des mini virus auch sein
außergewöhnlich komplexes genom
unterscheidet es deutlich von anderen
wehren mit mehr als 1,2 millionen
basenpaaren besitzt es eine genomsequenz
die beispielsweise 40 mal länger als die
des corona virus ist es gibt daher die
these dass das mini virus uns
zwischending zwischen virus und
bakterium sein könnte in der
wissenschaft ist allgemein anerkannt
dass viren nicht als lebewesen im
eigentlichen sinne gelten da sie kein
replikations apparat und keinen eigenen
stoffwechsel haben viren werden daher
allgemein lediglich als organische
strukturen die dem leben nahe stehen
sind bezeichnet aufgrund des komplexen
genoms des was ist es denkbar dass es
sich im laufe der evolutionsgeschichte
irgendwann von einem komplexeren
lebewesen zu einem virus zurück
evolution irrt hat also sein
replikations apparat und stoffwechsel
aufgegeben hat um sich an
umweltbedingungen besser anpassen zu
können das wäre dann die fehlende
schnittstelle zwischen viren und
lebewesen hat der mann schon so lange
sucht und es würde bedeuten dass
manchmal die evolution so radikal ist
dass sie sogar für lebewesen eigentlich
essentielle eigenschaften aufgibt um das
fortbestehen einer organischen struktur
zu sichern wahnsinn eventuell ist das
auch ein wichtiger durchbruch nach einer
der größten fragen der biologie
überhaupt wie es das leben auf unserem
planeten entstanden denkbar erscheint
dass die vorläufer des komplexen lebens
das heute auf der erde existiert
organische strukturen wie das mini virus
waren also biologische entitäten die
zwar noch nicht alle merkmale des lebens
auf wiesen aber die fähigkeit zur
evolution besaßen und letztlich dann
irgendwann den entscheidenden
entwicklungs biologischen durchbruch zum
lebewesen geschafft haben jetzt stellt
sich natürlich die frage ob die mimi
viren die von dem chinesischen
forschungsteam aus dem marianengraben
nach oben geholt wurden für uns menschen
gefährlich werden können da kann ich
euch zum glück ein bisschen entwarnung
geben in einigen experimenten waren die
minimieren zwar in der lage
gewebeschäden bei säugetieren zu
verursachen aber bisher gibt es keine
hinweise darauf dass sie den menschen
wirklich erheblich schaden können hoffen
wir mal dass jegliche mutationen
ausbleiben und wir vor dem mini lockt
dort verschont bleiben vielleicht haben
wir es hier aber auch erstmalig mit
einem netten virus zu tun denn es stellt
sich ja die frage warum gerade solche
riesen viren in diesen unwirtlichen
dunklen und nährstoffarmen tiefen des
marianengrabens überleben können das
wirkt ja erstmal paradox und deswegen
hat das chinesische forschungsteam eine
spannende hypothese aufgestellt dass
mimi virus könnte den organismen der
tiefsee helfen sich besser an die
eigentlich lebensfeindlichen bedingungen
anzupassen es könnte sein würden wie
pilzen und einzelligen tieren einen
boost verpassen indem es beispielsweise
den abbau der aufgenommenen
kohlenhydrate beschleunigt ein
schnellerer stoffwechsel und ein
schnelleres wachstum könnten den wirten
und damit dann eben auch ihren viren
einen wettbewerbsvorteil im challenger
tief verschaffen wo die nährstoffe knapp
sind und der evolutionäre wettbewerb der
wenigen widerstandsfähigen bewohner
absolut brutal ist das heißt während
wären ihre wirte normalerweise schamlos
ausbeuten könnte sich diese parasitäre
beziehungen einer extrem umgebung wie
den marianengraben ändern das mini virus
ist also nicht nur wegen seiner größe
und seines genoms einzigartige sondern
auch in der art und weise wie es mit
seinem wirken interagiert grundsätzlich
kennt man so was ja aus der natur das
zusammen existieren von individuen
zweier unterschiedlicher arten das für
beide partner vorteilhaft ist bezeichnet
man als symbiose das kommt sehr häufig
vor hier nur ein beispiel clownfische
leben in symbiose mit seeanemonen
innerhalb von dritten gibt es viele
fressfeinde und die see anemonen
beschützen die clownfische durch ihre
tentakel vor feinden im gegenzug
profitieren die seeanemonen von den
nährstoffen die in den ausscheidungen
der clown fisch enthalten sind win win
das besondere an der konstellation
zwischen den mini virus und den tiefsee
bewohnern ist dass solche für beide
seiten vorteilhafte symbiosen bisher von
viren eben noch überhaupt nicht bekannt
waren man sieht mal wieder unsere erde
ist für uns noch mindestens so
geheimnisvoll wie der kosmos bezüglich
einiger räte sind unseres universums
habe ich vielleicht etwas das ein
bisschen licht ins dunkel bringt ich
habe nämlich noch eine große ankündigung
zu machen mein neues buch erscheint
heute es ist für mich wirklich eine
riesige sache und ich freue mich sehr
dass christoph mir die gelegenheit gibt
es hier auf klicks um vorzustellen das
buch ist ein reiseführer durch den
weltraum und ich bin super aufgeregt und
sehr gespannt wie euch das buch gefallen
wird in dem buch alte der praktische
reisetipps zu unserem sonnensystem
fernen galaxien schwarzen löchern und
dem multiversum was sind die top
sightseeing punkte auf dem pluto wie
viele urlaubstage brauche ich für eine
tour in die hand galaxie und gibt es
geld für einen wilden ritt durchs
schwarze loch all das erfahrt ihr in
meinem neuen buch das den schönen namen
können wir auf gravitationswellen surfen
trägt und das beste das ganze buch ist
voll mit dutzenden neuen zeichnungen von
mehr für mich ist das wirklich eine
große sache denn es ist das erste buch
das ich gemeinsam mit einem größeren
verlag veröffentliche und ich hoffe
natürlich dass es sich in der einen oder
anderen bestseller liste platzieren kann
falls euch das buch gefällt und ihren
nächsten urlaub im weltraum planen
wollte nämlich ein bisschen unterstützen
wollte würde ich mich total freuen wenn
ihr euch das buch holt um ihr helft die
bestseller listen zu stunden vielen dank
leute für eure hilfe alles weitere wird
deutschen und christoph erzählen ich
kann euch timms buch wirklich nur sehr
ans herz legen es ist eine fantastische
reise voll mit vielen spannenden
illustrationen und die perfekte lektüre
für alle wissenschafts begeisterten
menschen ich kenne ja schon andere
bücher von themen hier hatte aber noch
mal eine schippe draufgelegt also
unbedingt bestellen lesen und
weiterempfehlen klick dafür einfach hier
auf den button dort bekommt ihr das buch
ist es persönlich besonders wichtig dem
hier zu unterstützen seit jahren machen
wir immer wieder videos zusammen und
erzählt einfach zu den besten youtube an
dich kenne ich zähle auf euch ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran